[Music]
hi this is all Joe welcome to episode
172 of the Google cloud platform podcast
we're here at next and we're gonna be
talking to a lot of great folks today so
let's get to that sounds great let's do
it easy enough so I'm super excited to
have an old friend of mine come join the
podcast today dance gags how you doing
Dan doing well it's been a long time
it's been a long time dan and I know
each other through Adobe ColdFusion for
many many ways back in the day back in
the day yeah Dan you want to tell us a
little bit about yourself and what you
do so currently I work for Viacom and I
lead engineering teams building internal
web app suites for our content supply
pipeline from getting new music videos
and episodic content movies from ingest
all the way through to our central
archive and all of the different steps
that were required to make different
renditions and metadata and such so
fantastic and what do you do in here it
next so we are just starting our journey
into moving a bunch of stuff into GCP
and so this is kind of a learning get up
to speed on some of the various
offerings and kind of see from an
architect's standpoint what we can take
advantage of as we're looking to move
applications into gke and move media
into you know Google Cloud Storage so
this is kind of an intro to the whole
ecosystem for me amazing so I'm pretty
sure you're pretty excited about a
couple of the announcement that have
come out of Google next so there's been
some good stuff here the anthos product
looks amazing of course I don't work
personally in our cloud engineering
group I've kind of worked with them and
I'm a customer of them so they're the
one making those decisions but we've
been having a bunch of conversations
around dinner and stuff around some
things that have been announced here
this week yeah then you said that you
had a couple of things you wanted to
talk about that we're particularly
interesting to you yeah so one
professional and one personal
professionally my teams are building you
know micro service architecture right
size service they call it and so the sto
product looking for centralized
consolidated management and discovery of
our services being able to not have
every team that's building each one of
those services have to worry about how
to integrate Active Directory
authorization or make sure that they're
keeping our InfoSec people happy being
able to put that on
of and kind of outside of and apply it
to our services there's just so many
benefits to doing that plus it gives us
a lot more visibility across different
sets of teams that don't normally
interact hey I need a service well
somebody else already over here has
built this let's see if we can use that
so we're looking forward to that from a
couple of different angles and our cloud
engineering folks are really excited
about getting that up and going - what's
been one of your favorite things that
you've seen in session so far I know you
mentioned a couple of things but I'm
sure you have other stuff one of the
things that most like energize me I said
in a panel yesterday called the future
of health oh interesting with some folks
from consulting and industry as well as
people on a lady from National
Institutes of Health and and the Google
health representative that was literally
inspiring an energizing our from I'm a
big advocate of people having access to
their own data and owning their own data
and when you look at it from the
healthcare side like I would love
nothing more than to have all of my
health data where I can get my hands on
it and if I go to a new provider then I
can say ok you get access to this for
you know the next five days here's my
USB key right or I push a button and
cloud says sends it to his system right
it's even easier so that angle of it
appeals to me as a data geek so to speak
but then also the ability for me to
voluntarily push that into big data to
aid in studies and research and you know
anonymize it and say be able to tell
these research organizations you can use
my health data for x purposes and know
that that's respected and some of the
things that they were talking about that
are coming and that they're working on
trying to get industry standardization
and of course we have some government
rules that are going to force a little
bit of that or in the next year or two
is very exciting
I have several family members that are
in health care spaces various types of
providers and so that's that's something
that's always been kind of an energizing
thing for me to get in and talk about
and after having run of healthcare
startup for a few years - you know it it
really is something that's pretty close
to home it's amazing I've actually done
a little healthcare stuff in my past
life
to see that we you know Google cloud and
a lot of our health partners are
actually fulfilling something that
really means a lot to you yeah they have
one stat where was it the human genome
project took a billion dollars in ten
years and then that was in I think 2003
by 2010 I believe if I remember the
numbers correctly it took ten million
dollars and months and so the advent of
these machine learning ecosystems and
the big data and stuff to be able to
squash that that time and the cost has
to be nothing but beneficial for people
that are researching cures for diseases
and conditions that we are experiencing
now so it's just you know amazing it's
just exciting fantastic both dan thank
you so much for coming and hanging out
with us you bet on the show floor and I
hope you enjoy the rest of your next
appreciate you having me on so I am
absolutely delighted to have both Lauren
and I just sitting here with the two
marks one half of the Google Mark Club I
just want to be clear slightly over 1/2
as we have three and a half members
three and a half members it does mark
with us see not count no mark with oh no
no more oh wait so is mark with this
let's discuss this later so more
importantly Lauren and aza how are you
both doing today
I'm just pondering how many marks does
it take to promote Google cloud right
now so all of that
for them I'm a little tired we're two
days into a very very large conference
but everyone seems to be happy so that's
great yeah Lauren you wanna tell people
a little bit about yourself I know
people know I joke because I should
super famous yeah my name is Lauren
Buckman I work in the developer
relations team and I do developer
marketing and we like Lauren because she
understands developers because she has
been through many of their pain points I
just didn't know that that's what was
happening you don't have to know about
it at the time to learn the valuable I
try to deploy websites for clients in
the past and not knowing how to load
balance to WordPress sites I didn't
realize I was learning some of those
DevOps and deployment payment points
along the way but fantastic well we
brought you here today to talk about the
developer keynote we're having an
interesting discussion before we're
learning all sorts of interesting stuff
about how that came to be yeah we've had
a developer keynote the last couple
years at next but figuring out what to
include in it is really hard and
Lauren's got some more insights on this
but part of the reason it's hard is that
we use the phrase technical practitioner
and there's a lot of different people
with different interests under that
labeled yeah I mean when we were saying
okay like what are some things that we
can say as we're telling people about
next about why they should come it ended
up being almost a three page document
where we were talking about you know
what is the specific thing that a data
engineer will get out of it versus a
data scientist and you know not even
talking about app development and are we
going to talk about what it takes to
write your apps but like some back-end
stuff that you need to make work so yeah
it's a diverse group it is a diverse
group and all sorts of backgrounds we've
got folks have been doing this forever
we've got folks you have very tight ties
to operator we've got folks more like
myself who kind of dabble in everything
and you know we have approximate
knowledge of many things and we've got
folks who specifically focus on very
very small subsets of data science
related to specific industries and
trying to build content for all of those
people in a compelling way is we're
really challenging as it turns out and
as this event gets bigger and as Google
Cloud has more products it gets harder
it doesn't get easier with experience so
what's the solution there I mean do you
just keep abstracting upwards until
you're not talking about anything in
specific or do you
start breaking out into you know more
you know Akeno for data scientists in
the keno for developers Aniki know for
operators well we only have one keynote
stage which makes the lots of things a
challenge we have spotlight sessions
which are kind of like more tailored
keynote type things but I mean yeah the
temptation is there to abstract but as
our lovely podcast guests know and we
have people who don't talk about
anything concrete it's it can get a
little boring so I don't know if we
figured it out yet yeah I think you kind
of have to just say we're gonna talk
about one or two things in depth and not
everybody in the audience is gonna get
exactly what they're interested in but
hopefully it will be valuable because
they may learn a little bit about what
their colleagues or you know other folks
on their teams are dealing with so if
people didn't catch the livestream or
haven't yet watched the YouTube
recording can you give us a brief
synopsis if the sort of things people
actually saw on stage other than the two
of you so I'll start with the first half
and then maybe you can take over talking
about the second half Lauren so we
started out with an app that was written
by several of our PM's and product
managers and software engineers trying
to demonstrate bringing multiple of our
products together because one of the
things that we've heard from folks in
the past up next is that each organ site
google talks about their launches but
there isn't enough content for folks who
are trying to bring a lot of google
products together and that was our game
of life demo and we also showed
integrating with common tools like
jenkins and slack and we had slack ops
as part of that and then i came on stage
and told people all the stuff that they
already know but like hearing again
about how to have sustainable DevOps
practices and how you need a good team
and then lauren that's when you came on
stage and I was able to bring three
different customers on stage so we heard
first from a company called Wix we know
Wix it's like a website building tool
and so they demoed a new developer tool
they've built on top of cheese
and we actually built a chatbot on stage
in less than 60 seconds it's kind of fun
like checking out how you can find a
boat in the Bahamas and seeing a natural
language in her NLB yeah NLB
there it is oh yeah we built a chatbot
on stage in about 60 seconds and got to
see how that worked and then we had
Arctic come on stage and they showed us
and anthos demo which was kind of cool
the demo gods were not on our side at
that point and somebody had not actually
logged into Jenkins so we had to follow
it was super well done yes it was and we
now know that it was a live demo it was
not a pre recording which is good and
then we got to hear from this woman
twinkle Desai from Kohl's and she came
out and talked about how she's been
managing her SRT teams and then we had
many of your favorite dev rollers and
friends doing five to ten minute demos
of various things we had Emma who Anna
was on the podcast this week and on the
podcast in the past showing all of her
awesome pie and we had a captain big
query himself Felipe Hoffa nice in his
cape because he Gordon he needed a mask
but he also says that he's too pretty
for a mask so he was showing us all
sorts of cool stuff you can do with data
including the fact that you can now
delete data from bigquery which is
something that people have been asking
for starand talked to us about what is
this cloud run thing that everyone's
excited about and they deployed a
OpenOffice container Oh fancy cloud or
honest agent that I mean the point is is
that just cuz you have an on-prem system
you've got legacy code doesn't mean you
can't actually containerized stuff and I
think that's a super important message
for folks to get because a lot of folks
think they can't try the new stuff
because their codes old and no no
there's lots of folks who are putting
really old stuff like Fortran and COBOL
in containers and that's cool and then
cloudy not that Eric Eric Schmidt showed
up and he talked to the chief data
scientist I believe from the Golden
State Warriors and they talked about the
fact that the Golden State Warriors data
problems look a lot like the data
problems that a lot of big companies
have and then there was an awesome
surprise at the end and you just have to
watch the video to find out it's good
teaser teaser
I'm good at to use ice in a lot of those
showcases or the some of the dev rails
people that were up there are also the
cool demos that we're over in the dev
zone here at the Showcase floor so you
can actually play around with some of
the stuff that Felipe put together with
the BQ ml and of course Emma's pi day
experiment yeah I forgot that all that
stuff's here and there was a recorded
tour of the showcase that will hopefully
be up on YouTube at some point in the
next couple weeks too so people can see
did they capture the pizza Authenticator
that they had over there in the showcase
area they did in fact I think you can go
to it online from memory yeah all of the
experiments that came out of the new
online experiments team including Pete's
Authenticator are available online yes
if you need to know specifically what
area of the world that your pizza comes
from you can do that there are a lot of
harsh discussions it started a lot of
animosity there was surprising people
have feelings about pizza you have
Chicago deep-dish versus New York style
is like our tabs and spaces of the food
world right Philippe excellent well
thank you to both of you for coming and
hanging out with us here in the booth I
know it was a late night last night so I
appreciate you putting in the effort
thank you for talking to us Marquette
thanks guys thanks all hey everyone so
we're really excited to have URI and
Anthony here actually Anthony from
Google and URI from Scotiabank and of
course I'm here to I'm here both the
marks are here yeah both marks so first
of all URI who are you and what do you
do okay so guys thanks for having me on
that podcast and my name is URI latina
vich and I'm a senior cloud engineer
working for Scotiabank and right now I'm
building the platform cloud platform
based on Google kubernetes engine and
Google is our big partner in our digital
transformation journey that Bank is
undergoing these days for a number of
years now and we're just we're just
starting
that's how are you enduring google
kubernetes engine I really like it I
really love it I would say and this is
something that we found as a great
technology for a particular use case of
running applications and running
containers in the cloud and will have
the power of Jiki as a managed
kubernetes solution and
it's good yeah it's really like a tag
lines right guven is engine it's good
and so what was the what was kind of
summary of the announcement that y'all
had with Google Cloud oh it was another
great Google cloud conference this year
I really like the advancement that
Google cloud does in its technologies
any particular really like NFS how cloud
services platform got its new name and
all the powers that came with it and
this is something that Scotiabank is
interested in and our platform that
we're building is called cloud
application platform as I said it's
based on G key we're gonna utilize the
power of Anthes for that platform then
you've been working with Anthony on the
Google cloud team as well to kind of
help your team trained up on kubernetes
yeah exactly Anthony did great
kubernetes training for us some time ago
and it got team up to speed to a higher
level and yeah I think the coolest part
is just seeing kind of the excitement
across all the different teams that kind
of attended this training here and I
think that it's it shows just kind of
how broad the space for kubernetes is
right there's certain features that the
security team was interested in talking
about so we delve into that there's a
lot of networking specific questions so
it's just interesting to see how kind of
google kubernetes engine it's good it's
good
really brought like a lot of features
across these different spaces right so
if you look at like security we have
binary authorization if you look at kind
of some of the container native low
balancing for folks and these different
kind of specializations there's
something for them in google kubernetes
engine so it's exciting to talk about
you know with the team at Scotiabank on
that it almost sounds like we should do
a full episode on this Australia I would
be happy to elaborate and tell you guys
more about the exciting stuff we're
doing at Scotiabank so maybe perhaps
possibly stay tuned for what will
definitely be
and I would highly recommend to watch
the presentation by Justin Arbuckle our
senior vice president and he did a great
keynote talk on the latest state of
things of Scotiabank going to the cloud
so definitely stay tuned and check it
out
have you had a chance to get to any
presentations or sessions here next yeah
a bunch of them and I like what talk
about the G key secrets management
presentation there was a very good deep
dive on how you integrate G key clusters
with both third party key management
solutions but also Google kms and
definitely lots of things to think about
and also good connections to work with
and that was given by South Fargo right
yeah it was given by stocked Fargo and
also Alexander it's okay we'll have
links in this unit yeah I mean I think
there's a lot of cool talks you know
over the past couple of days and today
covering the entire ecosystem I'd be
interested in hearing you know since
you're doing such a deep dive on
kubernetes what would you say that top
of your wish list is that's a very good
questions and I can give you a really
big wish to have and in its full power
but we're working on that and the
partnership was Google is very
satisfying to us so I believe everything
that we need we'll get it done I like
that all right well I think we're just
about out of time you know anything else
you want to call out where are you gonna
be any other cool events coming up that
you want to talk about oh I'm very happy
with what we have here and I'm sure
there are more events coming like Google
cloud max next year but also the summit
that's happening in Toronto this fall
I'm excited too and looking forward to
visiting that fantastic well you're a
thank you so much for joining us on the
podcast and doing this episode with us
today thank you very much Horace and
Anthony both marks in Africa both marks
and Anthony
thanks to you Andrew Davidson from
MongoDB for joining us for our our daily
episode here on the show floor Andrew
how are you doing
doing great thank you having a great
time in next excellent thank you so much
for joining us very quickly I want to
hear about your experience here at next
but wanting you give us a quick like
MongoDB what is it
sure mom gonna be is the most popular
modern general-purpose database and
we're really excited to have mom gonna
be Atlas close partnership announced
this week with Google Cloud among gonna
be Atlas our global database as a
service everyone should go out and try
it free forever free tier for everyone
to get started and experience what
modern application development with a
database that doesn't get in the way
could be like got John here and I got a
couple of questions about next what is
your favorite thing that you've seen on
the next floor I gotta say it on a big
picture level I just love seeing the
level of excitement the level and all
the companies that are here everyone
who's coming here to really learn about
Google cloud platform to see how much
Google's really put into this that this
is very much a big part of the future of
Google I feel that energy so it's just
real talking to all of the community
members like MongoDB but all the others
who you're so open to working with I
love seeing that it's really fostering a
great community fantastic what's been
some of your favorite announcements here
so far so I'm pretty biased on that one
I really love Google announcing I'm
gonna be Atlas is an increasingly deep
partnership with Google including among
of the Atlas as a native part of the
Google Cloud console coming up later
this year just in general working very
closely together great support from the
Google team so short teaser for our
listeners I know we're gonna have a full
episode with you coming up later after
next but you want to tell them a little
bit about what we're gonna talk about
sure I mean we're gonna talk a little
bit about the evolution of databases
over time and why folks have shifted to
this new model of JSON document style
databases in MongoDB and and why getting
it as a service in the cloud on GCP is
just the easiest way to modernize one's
application stack I'm also going to talk
about Davidsons law fantastic well
Andrew thank you so much for coming to
join us today thank you so much for
being part of Google cloud we look
forward to hearing more from you in a
later episode thanks so much for having
me thanks so much for everyone here at
next joining us and everyone who came
past the booth it was great to see you
all it was great to get interviews it
was great
to get all the content we've got that
we'll be releasing in coming weeks so
see you all next year
[Music]
[Music]
you